the new Dungeons and Dragons movie is
drawing comparisons to an entirely
different and very popular franchise but
is that a good thing or a bad thing
here's what fans are saying Paramount
pitchers has debuted a new trailer for
their upcoming fantasy epic Dungeons and
Dragons honor among Thieves causing fans
to draw flattering comparisons to one of
the most beloved movies of the 2010s the
film which is adapted from the vast lore
of the tabletop role-playing game of the
same name boasts a stacked cast
including Chris Pine Michelle Rodriguez
and reggae Jean page despite this
impressive roster the project faces an
uphill battle though the Dungeons and
Dragons brand is as popular as it's ever
been Thanks to its inclusion in shows
like stranger things making a film or
television series as engaging and
satisfying as an interactive game as a
challenge Plus past adaptations haven't
quite hit the mark
[Applause]
regardless some fans have noted that it
shares many positive traits with a
beloved film from the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Guardians of the Galaxy in the
comments of the latest Dungeons and
Dragons honor among Thieves trailer on
YouTube one person aptly subtitled the
film Guardians of the Galaxy fantasy
Edition from the vibrant color palette
to the remix Led Zeppelin backing track
the trailer really is packed with
Guardian fives this could work in honor
among Thieves favor if it is able to
capture the magic of that film Guardians
of the Galaxy was a runaway hit that
turned some of comic's most obscure
characters into household names
overnight because it couldn't rely
exclusively on name recognition
Guardians of the Galaxy success was due
largely to the sharp humor and vibrant
direction of James Gunn hey that isn't
star Prince
Star-Lord oh sorry Lord now the tone gun
found in guardians of the galaxies being
felt in honor among Thieves with its
brilliant blend of humor with excellent
characterizations to many fans this is a
great sign that the creative team
understands the spirits of Dungeons and
Dragons It's supposed to be silly and
feel like you and your buddies got
together to play a game and joke around
for a little bit as one person said on
Twitter so the new d d movie is
basically Guardians of the Galaxy with
Dungeon Crawl I think that's something
we could work with sounds lovely quite
the opposite on the R movie subreddits
where redditors gathered to discuss the
new trailer for Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves one user wrote
people have been saying for eight years
at Guardians of the Galaxy felt like a
tabletop RPG Adventure being played by
actual players I wouldn't be surprised
if the pitch for this movie was just
holding up a Blu-ray of that movie and
then slapping on a Lord of the Rings
sticker or two the banter isn't the only
aspect of the trailer that Harkens back
to Peter Quill and his crew a perfect
example of this comes in the trailer's
first moments in which Michelle
Rodriguez's holga the Barbarian defeats
a team of enemies with her hands bound
meanwhile Chris finds Edgar in The Bard
attempts to saw his own ropes off on
some stairs you know what I'm
thinking this moment not only seems like
something that could occur on the
Starship Milano but it could also happen
by dumb luck in an actual d d game among
friends while the characters and their
personalities certainly resemble the
guardian's crew the overall feel of the
film is what truly seems to be getting
fans excited for Honor among Thieves if
the film can capture that familial
friendship that can be found in both the
Guardians franchise and the most Magical
games of Dungeons and Dragons it may be
a huge success
foreign